good evening and on behalf of Rose Hagan
the head of school and Michael Fox in
the Joseph Fox bookstore like to welcome
you to friend select school this evening
will include reading by Steven Levy from
his new book crypto followed by some
questions from you and after which you
may have your book signed in the lobby
tonight we're extremely pleased welcome
Steven Levy back to his hometown Steven
is the author of five books including
hackers artificial life a unicorn secret
about famous Philadelphia fugitive IRA
Einhorn and insanely great the life and
times of Macintosh Steven also has an
insanely great list of publications to
his credit including among others New
Jersey Monthly Philadelphia Magazine New
York magazine Rolling Stone and the new
york times magazine he is currently a
columnist for Wired magazine and senior
editor and chief technology writer for
Newsweek which recently published an
excerpt from Krypto he also has a very
interesting web page Steven Levy com
that you may want to visit among other
things you can read about how he
discovered the whereabouts of albert
einstein's brain I'm not going to tell
you the story except to say that while
Steven now lives in Greenwich Village in
New York any doubt as to see even being
a true philadelphian is that he
described Einstein's brain as looking
like a goldenberg's peanut chew it's a
great pleasure to introduce Stephen
leaving
thank you and thanks to the friends like
school and the joseph fox fur up
sponsoring yes it's kind of funny i
found out later that i didn't notice in
advance that when you write about
goldenberg's peanut chews they send you
a big box of goldenberg's peanut chews
so it took a few years for the
goldenberg's detectives to figure that
out but i did receive a giant box of
goldenberg's peanut chews you know which
i haven't finished yet so you let me
know I probably could spare a couple of
those that you know are the size of
Einstein's brain not exactly a dead
ringer sport anyway I'm going to talk
today as was introduced about crypto my
fifth book and it's always a difficult
process to figure out what you want to
write them out each book is sort of a
leap of faith you're going to spend a
couple of years doing it and you really
want to be sure to get the funds going
to keep you interested and one you hope
is going to 0 at the end of your journey
and back in 1992 this is not a book that
was written on internet time I came
across a conference in Washington t
Boston DC with a panel discussion about
cryptography these issues about this
field of cryptography I hadn't known
very much about it I was looking for
another book to do I just finished a
book called artificial life and it was
drawn in by the discussion it wasn't a
technical discussion was a political
discussion on one hand there was this
guy who was representing the Electronic
Frontier Foundation which was a sort of
digital activism group and he was
arguing that we should liberate this
stuff called cryptography for the
privacy of all the people and this guy's
name was John Podesta and on the other
hand were people from the government
saying that we should suppress this
because our national security depends on
us not getting the stuff into the
mainstream well this was 1992 and if
you months the fellow who was arguing
the cryptography should be put into the
mainstream joined the Clinton
administration and quickly started
arguing it from the government side
Podesta has actually now just left the
office of a chief of staff for a
president clinton but what drew me in in
that discussion was this clash and you
look for conflict in a story that's
always going to add something and then
as I looked into it more and I learned
about cryptography which is the study of
secret codes the use of secret codes and
I got drawn in warp and started to think
about that as a possible book topic even
so it was a little soon for that because
the subsequent photography was sort of
just bubbling up into the public
discussion in terms of mainstream and I
actually took off and wrote a different
book about the Macintosh computer that
was the only project I ever get that I
actually finished on time and you kept
to a schedule and I actually did it
start to finish in a year to coincide
with the 10th anniversary of the
Macintosh and then it was 1994 and by
then I was already into cryptography and
decided to make that my next book it had
some other things I learned going for it
by then one is they'd had fascinating
characters involved and when I write a
book I try to write it through people
even though I do write about technology
which i think is the important story of
our times and also I was convinced by
then this was a story not only of
importance but of lasting an importance
when you write a book you try to pick
something at least I do there is not
only going to be current the year it
comes out but hopefully for a while I
afterwards and ideally I like to write
about a subject which is just getting
off the ground that I could tell the
story for the first time but maybe years
from then decades from then people will
wonder how this got started so when I
wrote a book about hackers I hope I
answered the question that people might
be asking now see how did the computer
culture get started and maybe I could
turn to hackers and maybe in the future
when we're all controlled by robots
people might say well how did that get
started they could be artificial life so
I felt that this had that but I never
really thought that the book I wrote
would wind up starting off like this
Mary Fisher loathe whitfield diffie on
site he was a type she knew all too well
an MIT Brainiac whose arrogance was a
smokescreen for a massive personality
disorder the year the meeting was
nineteen sixty-nine the location of
hardware store near central square in
cambridge massachusetts over his
shoulder he carried a length of wire
apparently justin for services caging
material for some sort of pet this was a
typical purchase for Diffie whose exotic
animal collection included a nine-foot
Python a skunk and a rare genetic aneta
a fairy Mongoose lake creature whose
gland secretions commonly evokes severe
allergic reactions and people it lived
on a diet of live rats and unpredictable
moments with nips startled human
admirers with needle-like fangs and
owner of such a creature would normally
be of interest in Mary Fisher an animal
lover who at that very moment had a
squirrel in her pocket at home she also
had a skunk as well as two dogs a fox a
white-winged trumpeter bird and two
South American kinkajous tiffy saw she
was buying some page flips and abruptly
focused his attention on her in future
years wickd if he would be known
extraordinarily well known as the
co-discoverer of public key cryptography
and iconographic figure with Buffalo
Bill with shoulder-length blond hair
Buffalo Bill beard and bespoke suits cut
by London tailors but back in those days
he was a wiry crew-cut youth with the
angriest face I've ever seen Fisher says
and immediately began peppering Mary
Fisher with questions you keep exotic
animals then you'll need this and this
and this he took things out of her hands
to put other things in as he lectured
his rudeness appalled Mary but she
hadn't yet cracked his code now that
might be an unusual way to begin a book
about cryptography which after all is
you know this ancient field baseball now
mathematics and you know as a long
history and now it's perceived the sort
of technical but I wanted to make a
couple points by doing that one as I
said is this is a book about people and
I tell this story through people and I
really think that even when you talk
about a scientific discovery the
personality of the person making it
actually affects
discovery just this way an artist you
know will affect his or her own work by
the personality but there's another
reason for that and that is even though
cryptography can be perceived as a
distant impersonal subject I think now
that is something very very personal I
think it's personal when you send an
email and you send it whether it's to a
lover or whether it's to a colleague in
business that no one else reads that
male the male only is read by the person
to whom is intended I think it's
personal when you make a call on your
cell phone those things are very
convenient we use them all the time but
what really happens when we talk is that
our words go off into you know the
balance against a satellite get picked
up by radio and anyone can pick up that
conversation I actually used to know
someone who used to drive around Silicon
Valley with one of those scanners you
can get they used to be legal now
they're illegal to get a scanner that
can pick up cellphone conversations but
it's really easy to get an old one or
get one altered that you can still pick
up the conversations and this person
would you know happily drive around
Silicon Valley listen to conversations
is people you know these CEOs you know
drove around on their car phones and
they made deals and they in acquisitions
and they decided to talk about their new
products and this person went and sold
information to their competitors that
stuff is personal I think your medical
records are personal right now your
medical records probably live in some
file cabinet in a doctor's office but
increasingly they're getting digitized
or being on electronic files and they're
finding themselves on hard disks and
they're moving around from your clinic
to the hospital to the doctor's office
and it's very personal what's in the
maybe it's news about abortion or cancer
and it's very important and personal who
knows about that your money is personal
how you spend it how much you make and
whether every penny can be traced you
know to the person you spent it that's
something personal not something that's
affected by cryptography so in our age
now this subject which was once distant
is now very very personal and the book I
wrote is about some people who figured
this out about 30 years ago they what
was once distant
once the province of the government of
spies diplomats of generals was going to
be important to all of us was going to
be personal and they had to do two
things first they had to figure out how
to make this technology in a change in
such a way that we all could use to
protect what was personal to us and this
was important to them and the second is
after they did that they had to figure
out how to fight the government which
didn't want this technology used for all
of us now the keeper of this technology
back then was this government agency in
the United States at least called the
National Security Agency and this agency
really was the epitome of secrecy it was
founded by a top secret order in 1952 by
a president truman and it was years
before the name of this agency the
National Security Agency appeared in the
newspapers or even was uttered in
Congress and they had a virtual monopoly
on all information about cryptography
their mission we know now was to both
make codes for the United States and
break the codes of other countries and
just gather all sorts of intelligence
all over the world and basically snoop
all over the world to gather information
which they present these breathing books
to the highest people in government the
president and national security advisor
and people like that and they were very
protective of this information the head
of the NSA who eventually did wind up
testifying in Congress uh in more recent
years appeared a few years ago I went to
a session a committee session by heard
him speak and he said something which
sort of justified I guess who became
justification for why things were so
important why they had to be kept so
secret and he said that uh he's the
story from World War two they really
don't tell recent stories I have to go
back because of the recent stories of
course our secret and he said back in
World War two as we all know now we had
a lot of success breaking codes of you
know the Germans and the Japanese and a
newspaper reporter 1942 found out we
were doing a really great job of
breaking a certain Japanese code and he
wrote an article about it well the
Japanese got hold this article and they
changed their codes and according to
mike mcconnell who was then that the NSA
testifying in Congress thousands of
lives were lost in the Solomon Islands
because this newspaper reporter wrote a
story and the Japanese changed their
codes that was why we couldn't let any
information out about this cryptography
so when with Diffie the person in the
hardware store who you just met looked
over the horizon and saw that these
digital computer networks and computers
were going to be used I love the
envision cell phones but he knew that
this was going to be important to
privacy and started thinking about the
problem he ran up smack against this
embargo this monopoly and tried
desperately to find more information
about it and he began this amazing
Odyssey crisscrossing the country trying
to find anyone who could give him
information about cryptography as was
done in sophisticated fashion anyone who
could tell him anything point me to a
document and he would literally go and
talk to people and often find that they
couldn't talk to him at all because
they'd signed a secrecy agreement with
the National Security Agency if you were
a mathematician and you were doing
really interesting work that related to
cryptography the NSA might find out
about you and then they asked you to
sign something saying well we'll let you
in will give you more information about
this but in exchange you can't publish
any information you have to keep your
discoveries within this close community
and people did that and if they didn't
the NSA had the power to declare their
work secret or declare a pot in the
secret and no one could find out about
it there's cases where patents were
declared secret and even their inventors
couldn't get hold of the patents so this
is what diff he was up against and this
is how he and maybe a couple other
people who were wandering in isolation
at that point started to find more
information about cryptography and just
tried to pry a piece by piece out so
they could try to build these tools that
we were all going to need now things
were different today and in part because
of with Tiffany and I'll tell you in a
second what he did to change that but I
did you want to just talk a bit about
how different things are now in part
because of whip a couple things that
happened to me in the last year really I
made clear one of the things that we did
find out was there was a book a book
written in 1967 that did have a
an opportunity to read called the code
breakers this was a great book about the
history of cryptography back from
ancient times and it was it was very
valuable to him but when this book came
out of course they had a chapter about
the NSA and as a result the government
wasn't too eager to see it come out so
they got an advance copy of the book and
they you know the director of the NSA a
guy at the time in the 60s a guy whose
name never appeared the newspaper went
to New York to actually ask the
publisher not to publish the book this
guy Marshall Carter a lieutenant general
went to Little Brown and said listen you
know this guy con he's no good and said
these horrible things about David cod
and tried to get the book stopped and to
its credit the publisher didn't stop it
though Khan told me of once it over
dinner that he felt it wasn't because of
free speech the little brown stood up
the government because they put some
money into the book and I just didn't
want to lose the money they'd invested
into it and since I know a little about
publishers that really rang true but you
know that yes just stuck in my mind of a
couple times in the last year thinking
how different things are now
particularly about a year ago maybe a
little more when I went to interview
someone from the NSA which is sort of a
switch and in those rare times when you
get to interview someone from the NSA
you're not allowed on the grounds the
NSA itself in Fort Meade Maryland
surrounded by this triple electrified
fence and you know generally reporters
don't go in there but they have you meet
them at this place just in the grounds
of the NSA called the National
Cryptologic Museum is anyone ever been
there to the National Cryptologic Museum
maybe one hand it's sort of hard to find
you have to take the exit off the
highway that says NSA restricted don't
go here but it's a next to a gas station
and it's actually a nice building and
the National Cryptologic Museum is
really the NSA Museum which is you know
quite a switch from back for the way of
things where 30 years ago and they have
some things honoring some of their
people and talk a bit about codes and I
picked up one thing which you know
certainly didn't exist 30 years ago
called the National Cryptologic Museum
children's activity and coloring book
and this is quite a switch they have you
know a little logo of the Center for
cryptologic history with a quill and a
key and lightning bolts and there's
things you can color here's someone
doing signals intelligence sitting there
picking up signals and then they have
something about the Enigma machine which
was the German code which we broke
during World War two now at the time
when tiffy began his quest all
information about the Enigma machine was
still secret from World War two but here
we are now asking our kids to you know
decode the Enigma machine machine that's
kind of cool I always wondered whether
there was a some chip embedded in here
that maybe if some kid got all the
questions right and something would go
off in every recruiting office in the
NSA and they follow you through high
school and college and ask you to join
the NSA and another thing I picked up
was the National Cryptologic Museum
activities but which i found was
interesting a little more advanced
puzzles in here and they had a section
here called famous people and cryptology
from the museum's exhibits and one
person was interesting is that David
calm and it says uh you know the wrote
the code breakers and it didn't say we
tried to kill his book but that was in
there to another event which made me
realize all different things were
happened just a few weeks ago and I was
preparing the excerpt for Newsweek for
crypto being at Newsweek I really wanted
had the opportunity to make sure that we
gave it a nice presentation so I talked
to the people in the art department and
I said you know let's make this look
really nice they decided to send a
really great photographer Brian smail to
do sort of photo gallery of some of the
people in the book so we took a picture
of wit diffie and we he went off to
California and took a picture of Phil
Zimmerman who wrote the pretty good
privacy program and he went to Boston he
took a picture of Ron Rivest is another
great cryptographer who made an
important breakthrough in and ray ozzie
who was the greater of lotus notes who
use cryptography in there but I thought
it would be a good idea if he took a
picture of this kind in Clinton Brooks
who is at the NSA now Clinton Brooks
made a contribution
uh by being the father of the Clipper
Chip which a lot of people were
extremely suspicious of and it was
actually an ill-fated government plan
that I right about here but in his own
way I think Brooks made a contribution
and he did it for patriotic reasons and
I hope I treat him sympathetically in
the book I thought it'd be great if we
got a picture of him so I told the photo
wetter to call the NSA and get it and
see we can get a picture of Clint Brooks
realizing was a little unusual so about
ten minutes after my photo editor called
and asked for this picture my phone rang
my office in Newsweek and it was the
public relations department of the NSA
which is kind of a switch in itself it's
only didn't have 30 years ago but over
the years I have talked to the PR
department of the NSA which isn't like
many public relations departments they
really don't exist the whole press
conferences and talk about what they do
but they do deal with the press and sort
of a constrained way typically what they
ask you to do when you have questions
about the NSA is to fax your questions
out to them then they fax you a response
it's unattributed and written in sort of
this group speak that is very difficult
to extract any one or two sentences from
the first time I did this I was writing
an article for y or about this group
call the cypherpunks and I sent them a
group of questions thinking I'll get
some answers but it was impossible to
extract any sense from the answers so it
being wired they had a lot of space to
run we just round their whole reply
there and let people decide for
themselves but the public relations
department is calling they said well we
hear you want to take a picture of Clint
Brooks I said yeah yeah I said well and
this is an excerpt for your book that
that's coming out I said that's right I
said well can you send us an advanced
copy in your book and that you know just
struck me is well I thought back to
David Kahn who they had a copy of his
book months beforehand and here it was
all the time I was writing my book I
think of G the NSA they're going to have
a copy of my book before I wrote it
probably and at the very least I
wouldn't need to make backups because
they'd have the latest version but here
it was and the book it actually had been
circulating and corrected proofs for a
couple months and they hadn't got a copy
and even if you went to Amazon
dot-com for a little while to my chagrin
if you went to pre-order the book it
wasn't available yet but some people
with the uncorrected proofs that
actually sold their copies the book
dealers who were then putting it up for
sale underneath the you could pre-order
the book so the NSA certainly could have
got to hold it then and but I actually
found it quite encouraging that they
didn't have a copy of my book at that
point and you know certainly made me
think how far we've come that you know
from a total monopoly on the NSA to a
thriving open community like we have now
and the breakthrough that made that
happen was the one that with diff he
made called public key cryptography how
many of you know about public key
cryptography there's a few i'll explain
it really briefly because it i think
it's an amazing concept i call it in my
book the most important advance in
cryptography in 500 years David Kahn I
spoke to just the other night and he
said well I think you should make a
correction i think it's the most
important advance in cryptography since
the invention of cryptography which was
pretty impressive before with Diffie
before this breakthrough there was only
one way to do this practice of
cryptography and that was you would have
a message I have a message that I want
to stand and say to the back of the room
someone sitting there in the back of the
room in order to do this I would have to
have this key which is a recipe for
scrambling up the words in my text in a
way that the people in the middle if I
wanted to pass us in the back couldn't
read it and a person in the back would
have to have a copy of that same key to
reverse the process so i would take my
key the symmetrical k because we both
need the same woman I you know take my
document use it scramble up you know all
the words and it would be called what's
called ciphertext and I pass it to you
and you try to read it you couldn't read
it because the Miss jumbled and you'd
pass it back there are no one in between
would be able to read it except the
person in the back only because that
person has that same kid but there's a
problem with that in order to to get
that kid in order for both of us to have
that key we would have had to meet
beforehand to securely exchange that kid
I'm not going to put that key with my
message because if you get the message
you're going to say I can't read this oh
but here's the key and I'm going to use
the key and unscramble it
and you'd be able to read it and you'll
be able to read and you'll be able to
read it and everyone be able to read the
message that I want to keep secret so
maybe in this room we could meet
beforehand another k but what if i
wanted to do things like electronic
commerce were communicate with all sorts
of people you know all over the world
it's going to be difficult for me to
have excuse akyurek stages of those keys
to meet everyone individually and if i
wanted to buy something for a place like
amazon.com barnesandnoble.com i have to
go there and you know we have to go into
a room and shake hands and exchange a
cake it just wasn't going to work in
order to have cryptography work on a
massive scale and to do ecommerce and
things like that we needed a way where
everyone could communicate securely with
everyone else even if you have a method
beforehand so what with diffie and he
was working by then with a guy named
Marty Hellman at Stanford University and
thinking about this how this
breakthrough was changed everything he
split this cave a single key that you
used to use the scrambler message or a
scramble a single conversation he's put
it into two parts and maybe his naivete
and the fact that he didn't have access
to the good stuff in Fort Meade behind
that triple fence led him to ask
questions that normally wouldn't be
asked were you know try things that
wouldn't be tried because when you split
this key into two and in his vision
everyone had their own key this we split
separated birth into a key pair he
figured one part of this you could give
out to anyone which was really
counterintuitive and sort of a hora see
when it came to cryptography because in
cryptography normally everything secret
how can you give part of your key away
but he figured out how mathematically
that could be done so I've got this key
split into two parts one part you could
give away I can give away to every
person in this room it's my public key I
could publish it in a book I could put
it on the Internet I could you know give
it to an agency which is going to
securely hold this I could you know put
it in my forehead publish it anyone
could say it it's not going to
compromise the security one iota the
other part of the key however this is my
private key and I'm going to keep this
and and until you could pry my cold dead
fingers from it and
you know it's the it's not going
anywhere because it's my private key I'm
the only one in the world that has this
half of this K so if someone wants to
send a message to me I give my public
key to everyone everyone has it so then
everyone with that public key can use
that public key and you know use it in
the mathematical function it's a recipe
for scrambling to scramble a message and
once it's you know that voodoo is done
with that public key only one person in
the world can read it and that's the
person holding the other half of that
key a private key that's me so I give my
public key to everyone you could all
scrambled a message on the only one that
could read the message with this private
key and this enabled ecommerce and
enabled everything because via the
public keys can go everywhere and
everyone can communicate with everyone
else's securely it also had another
benefit here's my private key only I
have this so I could use this as sort of
a seal sort of a stand when I perform a
mathematical function with this part of
the key the private key that's almost
like a signature and it's actually more
secure than a written signature that
people can look at and forge you know I
put you know my private key on this and
do the mathematical function that's mine
only I couldn't produce this and anyone
who can verify it by using of course
that public key which I've given out to
everyone which everyone access to and
doing sort of a litmus test to see you
know gee did he really produce this
let's use this public key if it gets on
scrambled that's it it really was him so
now you can see that through this
breakthrough of dipping and helmets we
could begin to have commerce you could
sign contracts online doing this and you
know other things got built on top of
that and it was really fascinating the
way that happened because dipping in
helmand published their paper a few
months later three guys from MIT Rivest
Shamir and Adelman came up with a really
elegant way to implement this system and
they publish that and then other people
looked at that they came up with other
schemes schemes for things like digital
time stamping and schemes for digital
cash and all sorts of other ideas based
on this breakthrough and you had a
thriving community within a few years
that actually gave the government fits
because all of a sudden the monopoly was
gone and
things were very very much different and
that's the struggle that I really write
about in crypto what happened after this
community you know started coming up
with ideas and then company started
coming up to exploit these ideas and all
of a sudden the government was faced
with a paradigm shift with something
quite different they had to face the
idea that people were going to
communicate securely and what could they
do to stop it as it turned out they had
plenty of weapons of their disposal and
you know there was a battle took place
over the last two decades that happily
resulted you know just about a year ago
with the government raising the white
flag and letting us get hold of a strong
cryptography the encryption that we
could build into our systems and you
know we're beginning now to see those in
our products and companies like
Microsoft and Lotus can now build those
into their products in the strongest
sense so there were a couple problems
that I had though in trying to tell this
story in such a way where I got it right
and for a few years I was really worried
about one of the problems which was the
if you knew what we knew problem now
during the time this battle was raging I
was talking to people on both sides of
the issue the people who wanted
cryptography to run free and they were
talking about this joyous world of
crypto Anarchy where the everyone could
have very secure codes and everything
would be protected and on the other hand
there was the government saying the gia
this happens we're all going to be at
risk the terrorists were going to get
hold of it the child pornographers the
money launderers and you know it's going
to be very very dangerous and you're
going to be sorry that this happens and
it's very difficult to determine really
who was right because as you talk to the
people in the government sooner or later
they would get to the point where they'd
say you know if you knew what we knew
you would understand that we're a
hundred percent right and you know
that's the end of the case and what they
knew of course was classified
information they had access to all sorts
of stuff that was classified they you
know people couldn't see without top
security clearances and you know they
said because we know this and you don't
you know only we could make these
decisions and the people on the other
side just dismissed this stuff and they
said of course they're going to say that
it doesn't mean anything but I really
worried about that because it's quite
possible that if I knew what they knew I
might agree with them but how was I
going to know that they're not going to
give me a classified you know status I'm
not going to sit in the room and he'll
with top secret stuff and if I did what
good would it be because I'd like to
write about this and they're certainly
not going to give my everyone who reads
my book of security clearance so I
worried about this and I you know heard
of these stories about how people in
Congress sometimes would question the
NSA or get a little frisky and questing
the budget of the intelligence agencies
and then they would quickly take these
people these legend has it into these
secure rooms and this cone of silence
will come down they sweep the room for
bugs and they would know what they know
you know the people would you know tell
them you know all the top secret stuff
and then these people legend had it
these Congress people would leave the
room white face whispering to their
aides that we've got to give these
people whatever we want and that was
what I was up against them I really
worried about it and I had a great
burden lifted from me a couple years ago
when this group called the National
Research Council which is the research
arm of Congress attempted a of
cryptography policy so they gathered
this blue ribbon panel these panels
always get blue ribbons right and it
consisted of people from the
intelligence agencies but also critics
of cryptography policy and some people
who are in the middle and they were
given clearances themselves they got to
see the good stuff they got to know what
they know and they listened to it and
they you know uh got all these top
secret briefings from people overseas
and everything and they made a very
interesting conclusion they figured out
that and they published this and they're
uh you know the book they came out
afterwards that they said well we've
heard this stuff we know what they know
and it's very impressive stuff but guess
what you don't need to know what they
know in order to make your decisions
about this issue in other words forget
it yeah it's important stuff but this
stuff is out in the public the stuff
that you know is enough to make a
decision so that was you know a great
release to me that I can go ahead and
make my conclusions
well the way things should shake out and
the conclusion that I came was that we
need this stuff and I think the
government actually came around to this
this idea in the past few years as
people started talking about how you
know disasters could happen not just
because you know bad guys use
cryptography but because the rest of us
didn't have cryptography our own systems
the United States is a very vulnerable
country in terms of a digital attacks
because we're the country that's most
dependent on digital networks so by not
using cryptography to secure these
networks we're putting ourselves at risk
and we started hearing people talk about
digital pearl harbors and things like
that I think I was a big factor why the
government eventually did raise the
white flag one final thing before I
throw other thing open the questions was
in another issue that came up that
always comes up and you talk about
cryptography and that's the issue of
paranoia paranoia just seems wed to
cryptography maybe when you make codes
you have to if you're not a paranoid
yourself you still have to get into a
paranoid mindset because part of making
it a really good code a strong code is
imagining how people can attack it every
which way because the the slightest
subtle flaw in your crypto system might
lead to someone finding out how to break
that system so you have to envision all
sorts of ways that people could attack
and stay up at night and be paranoid
about it in order to anticipate what
might happen to it and this was sort of
a challenge because if people have that
mind frame how that mindset of a
paranoid it might be difficult to sit
and talk those people and get them to
share their secrets with you and that's
what a reporter does he goes off and ask
people to share their secrets a couple
times I found this quite challenging
there was one guy in particular a guy
named David Shum who really is one of
the heroes in my book is a brilliant
cryptographer who specializes in the
cryptography of anonymity he's a very
concerned about privacy and he thought
of you know some really brilliant
mathematical protocols come up with ways
to protect you know your identity and
use you know a cryptographically secure
methods in order to do that and
he started a company it was going to do
anonymous digital cash tom is known as
the father of digital couch he came up
with an idea of the way to transform the
money in your wallet the strings of bits
in such a way that you can counterfeit
it but he was very concerned about the
prospect that the government's might
adopt this form of money but be able to
trace every penny you spend which for a
lot of us isn't that great a prospect so
we started this company called digit
cash out in Amsterdam where he moved
some years ago and he was devoted to
this idea of anonymous digital cash but
a lot of people felt that David was
overly protective of his idea and that
he was blocking the adoption of digital
cash in general because he was so wet
the idea that had to be anonymous and
David heard this talk and he wasn't very
happy so this was the background for my
interview with David so I went out to
Amsterdam to talk to David and learn
about digit cash and I went out to his
company and he showed me the company and
metal of people there and then we were
going to spend the next day talking I'm
planned because I was doing an article
for wire but I was also going to gather
a lot of material for crypto so we plan
to spend the entire day talking so I
loaded up with tapes and you know
batteries you know you have to be a
little paranoid when you up collect this
information because you know your
batteries to run out and I set
everything up we want to meet at a cafe
then go to the next cafe and go to the
next cafe and talk all day so I set up
my tape recorder and David shows up and
I'm setting the table court and Davis's
before you start I got to say one thing
to you I said what is it David he said
you know people they say things about me
they say that I'm some sort of privacy
none they say that I'm some sort of
paranoid they say that by doing this you
know digital cache of making it
anonymous that I'm just over the edge on
privacy but that's not true I'm just a
businessman I want to give people the
choice if they want anonymous digital
cash that's fine if they want digital
cash that isn't anonymous that's okay
too i just wanted to make it a choice so
these people my enemies they say these
things about me it's not true i'm not a
privacy nut i'm not a paranoid yes yes
yes yes fine fine fine we start okay so
we start maternal a tape recorder I say
David okay let's just off the very
beginning where were you born where'd
you grow up
said oh I can't tell you that kind of
information but paranoia actually fits
it in a broader sense in this topic
because we don't yet have the means we
need for total privacy over the Internet
the government's just relaxed you know
its regulations and the email we use now
isn't routinely protected you talk on
the cell you can't be sure that someone
isn't listening we have to be paranoid
about the way we use information in this
age and I really hope over the next few
years will have to be less paranoid as
this stuff does get built in if indeed
it does into our systems and we are
protected in any case that's the battle
that is the center of crypto the battle
over whether we have to be paranoid to
get the fruits of this great digital
revolution that I wrote about not only
and crypto with my other books anyway it
was a privilege to write about it and
then I just had a great time and hope
that you'll all enjoy the book that came
out of this thanks a lot and I'll take
questions
computer literacy but are not techies is
there any are there any good user
friendly programs for our computers to
use to do our personal email i used to
use one three or four years ago called
tougher I don't know if you you know
that one in it it was kind of like the
public heat thing that you described I
had a password that i shared with
someone so it we could each it just went
like give gibberish and then we could
descramble it is there anything like
that now like if I wanted to communicate
with somebody and we should share a
password or all right don't you you know
there's a number of programs you could
use they're pretty good privacy which is
the program originally invented by Phil
Zimmerman and given out now is a
commercial product you can get that the
RSA company which was originally founded
by the free MIT professors you know went
through a couple changes in ownership
now it once again called the RSA company
they sell you know software that does
that the difficulty is of course that a
you have to install it yourself and put
it on your system and learn to use it
and it's not all that hard but it's not
as simple as just having it built in and
the second problem is of course that
anyone you communicate with also has to
go through the same process so if you
use one of these programs you can only
communicate securely with someone who
has the same program on the other end
Microsoft and Apple and places like that
are starting to include it in their
systems but until they have the switch
automatically turned on it isn't going
to be as easy as it should be for all of
us and I was just a Microsoft last week
I was talking to the people and they
said well there are some you know
problems and setting up the structure
the infrastructure for us to have this
but they're thinking about that and I
think that's really going to be you know
the thing that we want to say there is a
program called groove networks which
isn't an email program but it's a
program that lets people work together
on the internet that has everything
built in
that's the first of the programs that I
think are going to be the model for what
we want in the future say sending
digital pictures to each other you know
about how far away are we from having it
be just routine I think if three or four
years uh there's something wrong if we
don't have it which doesn't mean that we
will have it because in a lot of cases
in technology there's something wrong
but i would expect us to have it in a
few years three or four years against
PGP okay um Phil Zimmerman came up with
this program called pretty good privacy
which does just that it does you know it
scrambles your email someone how's the
other end you know they use of you know
they are private key to unscramble doubt
and he was very concerned he about the
possibility that the government would
outlaw cryptography in the United States
and at that point there was some
legislation of you know some language in
an amendment in the Senate that was
considering that so he decided that
instead of putting it out as shareware
the people would give him money for the
program he'd give it out free and he
gave it out free and this other guy a
friend of has decided that he had the
cell to spread it on the internet all
over the world so he spent you know a
day going you know using a pay phone for
some reason even though there was no
reason he had to use a pay phone but he
went all over you know the highway in
California going from one pay phone to
another uploading versions of it on the
internet and within a couple days people
over the world had him well when the
government found out the US government
found out about this they weren't too
happy because they felt that violated
their export laws and they started an
investigation that were fills them
remain in this other guy were targets of
the investigation which is what you're
referring to after a few years of
investigation and years during which
Phil had to spend a lot of money on
legal representation and and had to
sweat it out pretty hard they finally
did drop their case against him and uh
you know about a year ago Phil very
joyously in a public setting put PGP up
on the internet and send it overseas and
you know everyone raised the glass and
celebrate
yeah how do you benefit personally from
from using photography and how secure do
you really think it is given the head
start the NSA hat on I'm working on the
technology ok personally I I don't use
it I don't use it for it for email I
don't use it for email because I email
to a lot of people and you know most of
those people don't have during the
course of writing crypto i did get PGP
and sometimes people would ask to
communicate with me with PGP and to be
honest you know nothing I did I felt was
so secret did you know I would be
brought down if you know the government
or anyone else overheard what I did but
I had to learn PGP in order to do that
but I do miss not having it built into
my systems I really want it built into
my system I'm happy when I use a web
browser and I send my credit card
numbers and it flashes into what's
called secure mode and that means the
crypto switch is turned on and from then
on every information you put into your
browser this gets sent off is secure and
then when you stop sending the
information it says okay you're leaving
secure mode and I ask myself why leave
why not be there forever the second
question is you know one that I think
it's impossible to answer I think
essentially you're asking gee the NSA is
so sophisticated how do we know they
can't break all the codes they're used
commercially and the answer is we don't
know they can't break it and there's a
good chance that some of the stuff they
can break now mathematically these codes
are very very strong the mathematics of
its barrel and the only way one would
think you could attack these codes is by
the what's known as a brute force attack
meaning drawing every different key
combination until you get the right one
but in practice the way these things are
implemented sometimes there's mistakes
sometimes you know there's you know of
ways that the actual chips on your
computers you know it might affect you
know but the way these codes work
and the NSA can figure that out and
exploit it so it's quite possible that
there are some very sophisticated ways
to break some of these codes and the NSA
may well know about this though I
haven't seen any press releases yet
saying they break any of the programs
yeah developing
in policy legislation about giving trust
to the key granting authorities because
you talk about cryptography is being so
wonderful but if Microsoft is going to
be the key granting authority of my
public and private keys I personally am
not going to trust them a whole lot
there seems to be quite about quite a
bit of debate about what the legal
requirement should be for a key granting
Authority and the second is related to
how vulnerable are these encryption
systems and it seems that every couple
of months now we hear about a contest to
hack a popular encryption scheme and
they seem to fall pretty fast let me
know the Dec SS although they obviously
didn't want that cracked and now there's
a SD mi has been asking people to try
and hack them and it seems to fall
pretty quickly so I mean really how much
of a danger is the hacking when you said
it's not clear but it seems if if it's
if it's falling already we seem to have
a problem that's not being discussed
enough calles your second question first
I think those contests are great I think
the idea that these systems are being
you know published and you know open for
challenge is the best way to get
security the only way you're really
going to know that a system is secure or
the closest you're going to come to
knowing a system is secure is knowing
that the best people in the world have
tried to attack it and have an attack
now since the NSA who's probably
certainly among the best people in the
world aren't going to tell us whether
they can break it we have to rely on
people not connected with the government
to you know tell us whether these
systems are strong or not now presumably
any reputable company which comes out
with a crypto system is going to test it
internally but you also want them to
make it available you know for others to
try to bang their heads against it and
try to break it in every way so then we
can find out if hundreds of people who
are really knowledgeable great crypt
analysis can't break a code then we can
be fairly secure that some high school
kid down the corner can't break it you
know you can't ask really for more than
that because every time you adopt a
cryptosystem your
a relationship of trust with that and
you don't have a hundred percent
guaranteed that then was going to break
it but certainly it's better than using
nothing so I'm very happy that places do
open their systems up for challenge and
you know they're collaery of that is if
you're something's broken then change it
the problem with the DVD crack is the
this is the system by which our DVDs we
watch movies on their encoded so we
can't copy them and you know give them
to each other for free they're encrypted
and presumably that Krypton protects
them but some 15 year old kid in Sweden
broke that system which makes you wonder
how great the system was to begin with
and the response of the movie industries
was to say instead of switching our code
because we have a lot invested in it
we're going to make it illegal for
people to share information about that
code which itself is a questionable
legality that's being challenged in
court there your other question is a
little more complicated I simplify
things but I talked about how easy it is
you know just to give out a public key
and everyone can use it the difficulty
with that is I give out my public key to
everyone maybe you know i'll give it out
you could see that i'm giving out the
public cave you could be sure about that
but when you take that public key i
given in this room to someone else you
know that person can't be sure you know
depending on how much he trusts you how
much yeah whether that public he really
is from me so in order to have a totally
secure means of distributing these keys
you have to have some place at least
where you could be sure that you know my
public key really is Michael the key so
you have to set up these authorities you
know to make sure that our secure their
certified to distribute these keys so
you know you can go to some place and
say gee I have Steven Lee these of you
know like a male here I want to test a
signature how can i get a public key in
such a way that i really know this is
his now you don't trust Microsoft they
do it a lot of people might trust
Microsoft but ideally we'll have a
number of places you know that securely
you know I and with authenticity and
store keys and you know like Microsoft
maybe you can go
Lotus or maybe you can go to the post
office maybe they'll do that and
there'll be a number of places they
could all you know how Stewart copies
the key they could they could be
multiple copies and ideally they you'll
find some place you like yeah to be able
to do that at least that's the way I
envisioned I think cryptographers is
usually being so libertarian which
that's maybe an over simplification of
their position but when you really dig
down to it when you get to the
construction of trust it's not about an
algorithm it's about something different
it's about the structuring of of a truss
system built around not just the numbers
but around the people who are going to
use those numbers and going to grant
certificates so do you do you see
attention in that in the sort of the
developed so the cyber libertarian ethos
versus how it's going to actually be
implemented well there's an absolute
tension to that in last chapter of my
book I sort of you know put a pin in the
balloon of the idea of crypto anarchy
because it is an ideal and it's one
there is I think a certain Beauty to on
one hand on the other hand I think it's
unrealistic to think that you can
conduct all your business in a
cryptographically protected cyber world
and somehow permanently avoid all sorts
of authorities you've got a body in the
real world that can be arrested and put
in jail if you do some really horrible
things and you know I don't think you
know you could expect cryptography to
protect you from consequences there in
terms of key distribution you know Phil
Zimmerman did a very innovative thing he
envisioned a way that you could do
without these authorities where you have
this web of trust where you use the
example I used before ok everyone can
trust what I give you in this room you
see me but yeah if I give it to you and
you have a friend who trust you a lot
they're not you know a pretty strong
degree of trust there so he you know
condition that web of trust where if you
really trust someone and that person you
know has a reputation within the
community of being trustworthy then I
could trust that K and you know it's
scaled to maybe a very small community
maybe it could work with a somewhat
larger community but when you think
about the whole world using that you
know you could see where one
untrustworthy person can
you know gum up the whole works there so
maybe we have to abandon a strict
libertarian stance and you know and have
authorities that are certified by
outside agencies there yeah source and
the new PG is still open source at the
at the present time and and there is a
lot of concern in the community that the
clotheshorse PGP might have a backdoor
thrown in and there's a lot of people in
the in the community that says that
believes notice or should stay open so
that you know that there is no backdoor
written into the source because you
compile it yourself yeah through
throughout the history of this you know
almost every crypto system comes on
their suspicion of having a backdoor
which meaning which means some way
built-in where you know the creators can
get access to the keys I do a chapter in
crypto about the data encryption
standard which was created by IBM was
really the first code made for
widespread commercial use and you know
Bob to be used privately in some sense
to and the NSA saw this happening and
actually took a hand by working with IBM
and declaring their design principle
secret because they felt that no one
should really know design principles
about how to make a really good code but
as a result a lot of people were
extremely suspicious over the years
about whether this had you know one of
those fabled back doors where the NSA
can just basically turn on a switch and
read all the stuff in there and you know
so even for a program like PGP is as
your comment indicates you know there
could be a lot of suspicion there people
want to see the way it's written to make
sure there's no back door there now Phil
Zimmerman actually when I talked to him
recently he himself even though he's
still feel affiliated with a company the
bought PGP is pretty concerned about
this issue and he's trying to figure out
what he's going to do because he wants
to stand behind his code
uh be on the side of his fans the people
who supported PGP when it was you know
of just a rebel product well I think you
folks like you will have to make your
decision if you can't get hold of the
source code whether you want to make
that decision of trust were see if
someone else comes up with a system that
does remain open I think realistically
we're going to have to wind up settling
on some sort of standard where all of us
can communicate with everyone else in a
way that preserves our privacy and it
would be great if that system where
we're open and we could check that out
but you know if it's Microsoft who does
it we know that they're not inclined to
open up their source code and let us all
look at it so people who are ultra
careful and don't want to invest a lot
of trusted in those programs might have
to go elsewhere which would be ashamed
because then they can't communicate with
everyone else yeah technology and
paranoia it would seem that every
question has been asked of you so far as
to some degree and others steeped in
paranoia you know and what I'm wondering
is putting the technological community
to one side because the obvious your
book is based on interviews in the
technological community most of the
people here are involved to some extent
or another in the technological
community the the public at large it
would seem to me that the more
technological we become the less
paranoid people are when people were
told initially that their cell phones
could be picked up all over the place
people in stop using their cell phones
cell phone use increase people wrote oh
that their email might be a subject to
review by somebody else people to stop
using email email use increase people
will talk about questions about secure
or unsecured sites with regard to credit
card numbers the e-commerce took off I
mean it just seems to me and maybe it's
an oversimplification I want to give
what your response would be so the
public at large these issues are not
really as important and maybe the public
at large is not as paranoid as a
technical logical community might be
that might be out of ignorance but i'm
wondering if you find that this is a
concern that's more restricted to the
technological community than
the public at large I think there's a
paradox in the way people view privacy
and you put your finger on some of it on
one hand there's a lot of studies done
that ask people how concerned they are
about privacy and in every one of these
studies a very high percentage of people
say they're very concerned about privacy
and then as you indicate you know you
know people will behave in a different
way they'll talk on cell phones they're
not only you know insecure where you
know the signals go but they'll be in a
room full of people and say very private
things from there into the conversation
and let people over here people will say
my privacy is important on the internet
and then someone offers them a chance to
win a yo-yo on a website they'll fill
other personal information and then then
send it off even though they don't know
what's going to happen that personal
information I think the answer has got
to be why not give the people what they
want when they thought those surveys
because it seems to me that universally
people faced with a choice of two
programs one is this is an email program
that gives you privacy and the other is
same exact program except no privacy
then you're going to pick the one with
privacy that way when Scott McNealy
who's the head of a son says you know
you have no privacy get over it you
could say well I choose privacy I have
an opportunity to choose privacy the
fact is it's difficult to you no matter
how paranoid we are to live our lives in
such a way to protect that privacy
especially with all the advances we have
in technology that every single one of
them compromises our privacy we want to
get the advantage of that so that's more
important to us than giving up our
privacy wanted you know an incremental
basis and you know by and large like the
communications I make when I wrote the
book any given message isn't going to
you know really ruin my life but if you
ask me whether I prefer it out privacy
the answer is yes and I think most
people are the same way
passage of the the income tax laws and
you know the beginning of the 20th
century people were concerned that they
were going to give a terminus amount of
the privacy by giving all this personal
information to the government and as
time went on it people began to realize
you know there's 200 and some million of
us out there they don't care i can write
whatever I want and I can say whatever I
want the odds of them catching me are
remote unless what i'm saying what i'm
doing is somehow detrimental to the
government's welfare but i can i can i
can download pornography and i can go
buy some junk and I can say what I want
to say and if somebody finds out about
it I really don't care and I and I'm not
saying that that's prevalent but I'm
saying that it seems to me that the
longer that you are exposed or the
longer the public is exposed to this
concern with the limited attention span
that all of us seem to have the less
concerned we are about because it
becomes a fact of life like you said I'm
not saying anything which is any big
deal i don't care people know it or not
right but on the other hand there have
been cases in our recent past where
these compromises and privacy you know
we're devastating to people times where
the government did violate our laws and
gathering information about people and
you know uh you know I think you know
there's no guarantee that that won't
happen again even though I was insured
endless times by people in the FBI and
you know the NSA that you know that's
for our distant past that's not going to
happen again but i don't think that past
is all about distant and i don't see any
guarantee that that won't happen again
and you know I I think if the government
were inclined to engage in that kind of
activity it would be nice to people how
to way to protect themselves yeah good
deal of time in your book talking about
the Clinton administration and you noted
that eight years ago as a new
administration they were very
susceptible to the NSA scare tactics
since we just brought in a new
administration what what are your
thoughts on this happening again or is
the genie out of the bottle has are we
going to go backwards what are your
thoughts in the next administration
right um yeah you're right um it was a
shock to a lot of people when the
Clinton administration uh you know
very quickly is one of the first things
they did when they took office in 1993
got behind this Clipper Chip and you
know it's really cited with the FBI and
the intelligence agencies on this people
in the clinton ministration told me and
this is sort of instructive now the new
administration's coming in that g the
people in power you know that in these
agencies you know the permanent
government as it were gave us these
choices on one hand they said well i
guess you could a ban all cryptography
and that didn't sound too great to the
Clinton people because they'd have to
search everyone's hard disks and you
know it probably would cost an ill will
on the other hand they said well you
could let everything you know
cryptography run free and then we have
all these terrorist acts and things like
that that didn't sound very great to
them so they said well there's this way
in the middle this is you know key
escrow idea and that's what ready to go
why don't you sign off on that they said
well it's great that's that's in the
middle we'll do that in a few years
after they signed on to that someone
from the the White House told me that he
was you know thinking about historical
precedent and said it was a lot like the
Bay of Pigs when Kennedy came in that
they said that you could you know do a
full-scale invasion of Cuba or you could
do nothing about Cuba or you could do
this thing in the middle this little
idea we have with the Bay of Pigs and
that sound good to them so there may
well be something similar now I think by
inclination and I've heard you know a
bush and talk to some of the technical
advisors you know it seemed to be in
favor of this administration but they're
not inclined to roll back you know these
the other government concessions have
been made in the past couple years on
one hand on the other hand I think there
is a danger that you know for the day
that might come and i think it probably
will come where a horrible act is
committed and the government couldn't
find out about the act because the
perpetrators used encryption and they
couldn't hear the messages they couldn't
hear the conversations read the messages
and because of that they might say
whether it's true or not that we
couldn't stop this where we otherwise
could have stopped it and i think at
that moment you'll see you know louis
freeh if he's still the head of the FBI
march down the Congress
and do as he's promised to say we've got
to stop this now this is this is a
danger I think that's going to be the
test if there ever is going to be a
rollback it's going to be when that time
happens and i have to say that i think
there's a good chance that at some point
down the line particularly if we have
the stuff built into our systems
something like that will happen and
it'll be interesting to see if we stand
up and say you know this was a trade-off
that we anticipated in exchange for all
our privacy's we've given up something
and that's a consequence of that ok one
more respect undirected there's another
person would enhance the question about
that I'm not mistaken I believe Great
Britain passed a law at least at least
had a law at some point that or at least
was proposing a law that would have made
it mandatory for all computers with
encrypted hard drives to have that
undone and let the government see upon
request or face prosecution or but
anyway my question is with that and
similar things in other countries going
on what do you think is the global trend
both in regulation of a creek of
encryption and adoption of encryption
among ordinary people globally I think
countries come down pretty much for you
to expect them to come down on that you
know the UK as a country that has an
official secrets act they're more
restrictive than we are when it comes to
free speech issues so it's not
surprising that they would endure
something like that it's not surprising
that you know China and Singapore isn't
dancing in the streets of the prospect
of cryptography being built into their
systems there I think as this stuff
becomes prevalent you're going to see a
lot of suspicion on behalf of
governments particularly governments
that don't have agencies that are going
to be able to gather intelligence
through other means and I think that in
other countries don't may have to go
through the equivalent of the battles
that we've been through and maybe with
different outcomes but I think if this
stuff is being built into standard
worldwide systems it'll still be tough
to stop
and you might see you know things like
countries like China refusing to go
along with global standards if they're
that unhappy with the protections that
are built into systems like like
Microsoft's thank you